[Music]
I miss the 90s the music was better the
world was simpler and Costa Coffee
didn't glamorize young women cutting
their tits off admittedly I'm old school
I go to a coffee shop to buy coffee then
again a double mastectomy is more
appealing than the foamy discharge that
passes for coffee at Costa it's not
enough for companies to service their
product they now tell you what to think
a large latte with oat milk no problem
would you like a bit of Top surgery with
that oh sorry sir you haven't collected
enough stamps on the loyalty card how
about some puberty blockers for the
weekend we wouldn't do this with men
Starbucks wouldn't celebrate men taking
female hormones and irreversibly
medicalizing their bodies for the rest
of their lives
thank you
[Music]
foreign
moving stuff but let's be honest what
happened is a little more than adding a
letter to a name Starbucks priced that
advert in India to be fair to our Peter
you must be really committed to being a
woman if you transition in India the
only country in the world where cows are
more respected than women that's like
Rachel dollazole deciding she's black
building a time machine and traveling
back to 1920s Alabama when I was CR
Peter I think you know what darling
you've earned it the character of our
Peter is played by a trans model called
Sia if Sierra is happy with their
transition then great live your life I'm
just not comfortable with corporations
promoting surgeries and medical
interventions which are incredibly
damaging to the human body and in many
cases irreversible they may help some
people but for others they cause
lifelong regret and huge suffering the
most Insidious part of this movement is
self-id which means anyone can identify
as a woman all you need to say is I'm a
woman and boom for legal purposes you're
a woman and they're not women they can't
give birth menstruate or remember an
off-the-cuff comment you made six years
ago and then bring it up in an argument
this self-id policy has led to
horrendous situations where male rapists
have been put into women's prisons
that's right if a male rapist says he's
a woman then he must be a woman there
can't possibly be an ulterior motive
behind his transition maybe it was a
gender dysphoria that led her to start
raping women with her penis have you
thought about that you're miserable
transphobe the case of Adam Graham sum
this up the best Adam is a convicted
two-time male rapist just before Adam
was convicted he developed p-o-g-d
prison onset gender dysphoria it's a
tragic disease that seems to afflict
male sex offenders they get convicted
and then Shania Twain's Man I Feel Like
a Woman starts playing in their head the
only cure for this disease is to buy
pink Primark leggings show off your
shapely clitoris get a blonde wig and be
placed amongst vulnerable women although
these are Scottish women so they could
very well end up assaulting him there
were hint Adam was a woman before she
and announcer transition it's the little
things that tell you like the fact she
has a very feminine and beautiful face
tattoo you can't even attend a yoga
class in Brooklyn without seeing a whole
host of yummy mummies with face tattoos
reminiscent of Mike Tyson but we should
all give thanks to Adam AKA Isla Bryson
because without her we would never have
had this beautiful Moment Like trans
women are women but in the prison
context there is no automatic right for
a trans woman in our context where a
trans woman is not a woman no that is
there is circumstances in which a trans
woman will be housed in the male prison
estate is that any context in which a
woman born as a woman will be housed in
the real estate look we're talking here
about trans women I'm now asking about
women born as women I don't think that
our circumstances there but it's
different for trans women well yes and
I'm not so they're not equal because
trans women are women even when they're
male rapists with face tattoos I would
let Adam identify as is anything she
damn well pleases if it meant she
continues to expose ideologically
compromised politicians this ideology
has also impacted women's sports turfs
or trans exclusionary radical feminists
have said that trans athletes shouldn't
be allowed to compete with biological
women as they have an unfair advantage
of course they do they've been through
male puberty have thicker bones more
muscle density and don't menstruate I
believe trans women are biological males
but they should still be allowed in
women's sports it's the only way to make
women's sports interesting no one cared
about women swimming before apart from
athletes coaches and perverts bernalia
Thomas has come in and everyone's
talking about it imagine if Leo joined
the WNBA they might even be able to draw
a crowd I think we should bring back old
sporting Legends to play in women's
sports let's get Michael Jordan in a
weave smash a couple of implants in her
and then watch her dunk 100 points in
the women's NBA who wouldn't want to
watch Davina Beckham smash 12 goals plus
a US Women's team plus David's so
handsome she looked better than most
women I've dated course not to love a
woman you can objectify and not be
canceled for staring at now that's what
I call progress
foreign